hey good afternoon everybody it's uh
it's the end of the week it's the uh
what is it March uh 28th and it's 3 o'cl
you know markets are just winding down
it's been uh another interesting week in
the markets you know it's like every
ever since Trump got reelected uh you
know the markets uh have been not
disappointing Traders let's just uh put
it at that and it gets uh sometimes gets
a little bit hard to sit in front of the
screen for hours at a time uh you know
with the way the markets move up and
down uh very fast you know it's you know
sometimes the market moves we don't know
what's causing the market to
move simply
because you know the news cycle the the
news that comes out is a bit slow right
we got to go on Twitter we got to go
look it up um what's moving the market
and that's why having an automated
trading uh system or method is is going
to help Traders that's why U you know
paabo and I are doing this special
presentation on how you can automate uh
using his markers plus software as well
as my orderflows software we're going to
go talk about uh one specific tool that
I released uh called the toolbox which
takes the different parts of
orderflow and lets you basically create
your own custom indicator and you know
when it's coupled with markers you know
now you can take what you like to look
for on the footprint and put it on
basically create your own indicator with
it so let's jump into it so before we
begin you know it's we're all adults
here in the room and there is just brief
disclaimer you know trading does involve
risks and you know you should only trade
with risk capital and you know not money
that you need to live on all right so
just basic Common Sense stuff don't uh
trade your your rent money so to speak
so automated trading you know is is it
for you and you know some people think
that um automated trading isn't for them
because you know they want to analyze
the markets that's fine but if you
really want to level up your playing
game right you have
to be at a level where you can take the
trades where you don't have to
necessarily think about uh you know
should I take this trade should I not
take this trade right and especially in
this environment this Market environment
that everything moves so quickly you
know like like on a dime sometimes you
know there's times where we literally
sell off all morning I mean like right
now we're down you know just near our
lows and you the first hour trading
looks like it's going to be a big Trend
day down oh it's going to be an easy day
for TR for the market because it's going
down but then all of a sudden it just
turns on a dime and it starts railing
like you know like a bad out of hell
where it just keeps going up up and then
we make a new high you know it's it's
insane and really that's where having an
automated Trader helps you in your
trading because it sort of removes One
Step you know that that step where
you're sort of married to um a view of
the market you know sometimes we come in
we're thinking you know the first hour
of trading we see the market sell off
all day in our mind subconsciously we're
thinking oh this is a trend day down and
we're going to be spending um more time
thinking about getting short because the
market just sold off 40 points right off
the cash open that we Overlook that the
market is
rallying okay and you know having an
automated system that will follow your
own set of rules that you set up is
going to help you you know in the end as
a Trader and you know we're going to
talk about how to you know automate with
the markers all right so you know a lot
of people think that automated trading
is is just like this you open up your
laptop and money comes spitting out of
it if it was only that easy um that's
just not the reality I wish it was but
you know one of the first things I said
before you know we begin this
presentation is you know trading
involves risk and what if you could
remove some of that risk right by having
an automated trading system and what do
I mean by by the risk is well the risk
is overthinking right as humans we tend
to overthink things right ah you know
what I'm going to give this uh set up 10
more seconds to play out make sure it's
going in the right direction well in
those 10 seconds that could be the move
that you're looking for especially in
this market environment now there's two
different ways to use automated trading
okay there's fully automated which is
basically you know trade entry trade
exit you know where you set up your you
you have your signals right in the back
end you you could set it up I'll talk
about uh setting up your trading signals
and fully automated would be you know
okay you got my takeprofit I got my stop
loss right it's either going to go to my
take profit or it's going to go to my
stop loss right one way one way or the
other and there's partially automated
which is trade entry to get you in right
so you're not second guessing yourself
like you know there there's times where
you know as an order fil trator you know
the importance of things like uh a
stacked in Balance right just really
basic stuff where it's like okay I got
it stacked in Balance but you know what
I'm want to give it I'm not sure you
know because of this Market Market
environment and you want to give it a
little bit more time so to speak to work
out well in that time that you're given
it to say work out next thing you know
the Market's moved it's made the move
that you're looking for right and that's
why you need automated trade entry right
that just does what it's programmed to
do like the Terminator right it just
goes takes the trade based on the
conditions and when I talk about
partially automated then you can manage
the trade manage the exit right manage
the exit or you know when I say exit
it's either your stop loss or your take
profit you know when you're going to get
out of the trade you know and it's
like you know when as kid you know you
see in the cartoons it would be like the
the good angel on one shoulder and and
the bad Angel and the devil on the other
shoulder you know one person one saying
I'll do this other's doing that and as a
Trader it gets very very complicated
okay and really that's to me that's
that's where
automation really comes into play
because one it gets you in the trade as
soon as the conditions are met right you
don't have to give yourself that extra
stress right because if you've
ever I'll say discretionary traded but
you know pointand click trading you know
I'm sure there's been times where you
look at the screen and you're like yeah
you know what I want to take that and
it's not quite up to par you know um
it's like well you know it's I've got
stacked in Balance but I I don't have
the momentum but you know what I lost my
last trade so I'm going to take it okay
that's where automated trading is going
to save you because it's automated
trading follows your rules right
everyone says um you know uh plan your
trade trade your plan right you you got
to have your own
setup rules in place using a tool like
markers helps you put that in not just
black and white but in the computer
right computers are there to help us as
Traders um
trade right it's not just to clot a
chart for you what you're actually using
the computer to help you trade so again
like I said I prefer partially automated
because I'm a Hands-On Trader right I
read the order flow
but at the end of the day
you have to ask yourself would you
rather get stopped out at your full
amount or stopped out at half or just be
happy to scratch the trade honestly
that's where managing the trade
um helps Traders a lot okay Ian we're
not um you know we all like to think
that we're brilliant mathematicians you
know that we could work at Renaissance
capital and create these alos that are
indestructible but market conditions
change right and as Traders we have to
understand that and we have to be able
to adjust that that's why it's for me at
least I think uh partially automated uh
wins over fully automated okay so the
next step is in order to automate order
flow you need to identify trade setups
okay now basically the computer needs a
reason to buy or sell so for
example if you're an orderflow Trader
most of you understand orderflow use
order flow footprint charts or orderflow
indicators um you know say a Delta
increasing by a certain percentage over
X number of bars right you need to give
the computer a reason to buy or sell
and let me just pull up a chart here
real quick okay so you know if you're
looking at this is the you know this is
just a footprint chart right and right
if you're looking at the footprint like
here we have a nice Delta Divergence
coming in you know right at the low
Maybe you put that in there you know
it's got to be a Delta Divergence you
know with positive Delta um or some of
these other tools right you could use
max Delta M Delta Delta percentage
there's so much um information in the
order flow that you can program now
sometimes Traders get lost in all the
data but what Traders don't understand
is what you're looking at on a footprint
chart is the market okay it's something
that tells you hey you know what there's
an big change right so like for example
on the order flows Trader one of the big
uh new additions that we made on our
software is Delta change percentage okay
so what it's doing is it's measuring the
change between bar one and bar two in
terms of Delta so this Delta went from
minus 8 to plus 867 that's a Delta
increase of
10,937 okay
so you can say well I I want to take a
trade when you know the Delta increase
is
over um you know a th% okay in this case
it's over
10,000%
and you know there's two buying
imbalances in the bar or two selling IM
balances okay in case the the Delta
increase was uh over a th% but in in the
negative sense here it's in the positive
sense okay you can you can do that right
because what I've done now is I created
a new tool it's
called the orderflow toolbox okay and
what it does is it takes sort of the the
different data points of order flow and
combine it so you can create your own
trade setup so for example right instead
of looking at your footprint chart like
this what you can do is you can create
your own indicator based off the
information on the footprint chart so
for example this chart
excuse me it's giving me signals based
off of the bar having an open point of
control stacked in balance and orderflow
GAP okay so you can see it's just giving
me the signals when those three
occurred here's another chart this one
has extreme Delta threshold momentum
strength and volume
imbalance sorry for
coughing and in the past right you you
never
we able to do this you know just by
looking at a footprint chart you'd have
to go in and the order flow trator is
really the only software that would
allow you to highlight these things you
know you'd have to go into the actual um
order flow Trader software and enable
what you want to look at to get the
signals drawn right like for example
down here
is the uh Delta Divergence right is
enabled okay so you know maybe you're
looking at Delta the
Divergence and something else so for
example right I I talked about this
extreme sorry the Delta change
percentage
with um buying imbalances okay so you
know what I would do then
is I'd find this the setting here
Delta extreme Delta change right set it
at whatever I want you know 1,000 okay
1,00% and then go to volume and
balance find it in here two set it to
two so it would highlight to
me the bar that has
both two buying imbalances or two
selling imbalances if it's a red
bar and a Delta change over
1,000% however the problem or not the
problem but rather the the thing on the
footprint chart
is it wasn't combining them okay so
example
here you can see here's my Delta percent
change 10,000 plus the bar has two
buying imbalances okay so it's giving me
that signal
whereas here
um let's find a different
one you know here's another one right
it's got the
two signals appearing so you'd have to
go basically look for every time there's
um the two signals appearing in there
actually I got the wrong thing enabled
but let's just pull it up here real
quick again take a look I got some other
stuff also enabled uh let's make sure I
turn off the other things really quick
where am
I Delta change threshold I didn't enable
that
uh no that's wrong one 1,00% delt to
change let me just turn off some of
these other things so I don't confuse
you there's some other stuff on turn off
the
ratio one control one control Point
control
balance value area
value
okay there sorry about that um I just
want to confuse you by having too many
different things going on there at
once so Health to change percent and the
volume IM balance make sure you're all
good
okay so you see right this one triangle
one triangle that's just telling you
this Bar's got multiple imbalance right
multiple imbalance
um this one
is is blue color because it's got the uh
Delta change percentage 2700 So it's
over 1,000 right but it doesn't have
both conditions
met okay you know nothing in here so now
basically what we're able to do right is
we can just pull up a nice bar
chart okay I do need tick
replay oh hang on just pull up a bar
chart here uh little this
select the minis I keep changing it
there we
go okay so here's my bar chart right so
with the
toolbox I just add the
toolbox then I could just
choose how to create my own indicator
here okay so
Delta change
percent oh my
gosh Delta change Delta change percent
here
1,000 let's give it a second
here okay so I just sorry guys I just
spilled water all over my keyboard um
these are the bars that have a Delta
change of 1,000 okay now if I wanted to
add another filter Delta change of
1,000 if I want to add the volume IM
balance all right I just click it here
to apply so now it's going to
Signal all those
bars that have
both the Delta change percent over the
threshold as well as two volume
imbalances
okay give it a second here it says
calculating all
right you can see you know here here now
there's other filters you could use you
know this is just one I picked off the
top of my head there's a lot you can do
um you know this is Delta breakout
momentum strength volume
imbalance um extreme Delta threshold
momentum strength volume imbalance as
well as extreme our
volume um you there's even some more in
here could just go through basically I
could create my own tools so say for
example okay Delta change a set at 500
but say I want to use uh let's just pick
something up really quick here so just
disable volume balance say I
want you know bars that have a thin
print and you know a small min max Delta
I don't know I'm
just picking this off top of my head
really quick but see how it looks all
right you can go through there again you
know most of us that trade orderflow we
have C certain things that we're looking
for in the order flow on a regular basis
right and having a tool like this my
opinion is just going to you know help
with your analysis right um You you can
refine it down to you know other
aspects you know whatever you want um
you could add more to it say it's
uh say you want to have where is it here
exhaustion print okay exhaustion
print
with let me get the what was that
pick that off you know a bar with an
exhaustion print and a small minmax
Delta right and don't worry if you don't
understand what small M you know all
these different tools are explained in
in the user guide and especially if you
have overflows
Trader you know you just go to
overflow.com
off8 all these tools are actually
explained in there but you can see you
know how it performs you know how it's
looking when it's combined um again I'm
just picking these off the top of my
head we do
have you know we've I've done webinars
uh user training webinars where I
discuss um you know very specific trade
setups that you can
use in different markets as well as um
you know what settings you're going to
adjust you know there's there's so many
different markets out there you know say
you're looking at gold futures um you
know gold is having some nice moves you
know whether you're a scalper or
something you could adjust all these in
there right I mean you can choose so if
you're using exhaustion prints there you
probably wouldn't use nine you'd
probably go down to something like a
three um to sort of clean it
up right you can see it's it's much
clearer here you're catching some nice
Trends
um uh do smallman Max Delta you could
even do you know exhaustion Prints Plus
you know bars that have
stacked stacked
imbalances as well or you know even that
bars that have stopping
volume stopping volume is one of the new
tools that we've added onto the toolbox
we've added actually 11 new tools um on
here now something like stopping volume
you could even adjust sort of the volume
percentage that's coming in to help stop
the the
moves all right so you know there's so
many different things that you can do
with the the toolbox you can create your
own indicator basically you know using
the toolbox now once you've you know
created your own indicator right next
thing you want to do is you know you
want to automate it okay so for example
well here let's let me do I'll show you
guys something really quick
here let
me go back to an mini
chart okay
here one of the things that makes the uh
toolbox sort of unique is that you can
actually add
multi-time frame analysis okay what's
multi-time frame analysis we see up here
period type so I could change it to say
a f minute chart so say I trade a one
minute chart and I'll just keep it
simple let me just turn off some of this
stuff Delta
change
that and I'll just use you know a very
simple thing stacked in balance
so what I'm doing now right is I'm
looking at even though I have a one
minute chart
up I'm using a f minute time
period right and I'm looking for what up
here you see up here in the corner
stacked
imbalances so even though I'm trading a
five minute
chart or sorry a one minute chart I can
take sort of higher time frame
analysis and put it on this
chart you can see on the five minute
chart stacked and balance stacked and
balance stacked and balance stacked and
balance and even down here late in the
day on the FIV minute chart there's a
stacked imbalance I'm looking at a one
minute chart if I wanted to manage it
okay so it's really a a
robust software for analyzing orderflow
what we've done basically is we've taken
all the information that we use to
analyze the orderflow all the different
ways
now you know there's point of controls
there's imbalances there's all these
Delta numbers
um so many different ways that we
analyze the order flows Trader what
we've done is taken all these tools that
we use to analyze the orderflow right
you know all these tools in
here and instead of having to look at a
footprint chart trade off of a footprint
chart because not everybody wants to
right sometimes you have your existing
chart using
um you know some other tools you want to
just look at a bar chart what we've done
is we've taken those tools that we have
on the footprint chart and we put them
in the tool box so you can create your
own
indicator based off of orderflow
information right not off of you know
all this information that appears in um
ninja Trader these are all our
proprietary our custom
tools for analyzing order flow and not
only can you use them you can combine
them in a way that you can't do that on
a footprint chart now there there's some
traders that have both the footprint and
the toolbox and they just overlay the
toolbox on the footprint they just keep
a plain footprint and they just want to
see you know based off of their uh
trading setup you know what they're
looking at in the
orderflow sign it on the footprint and
manage it from there but if you're a
Trader that doesn't want to use a
footprint but you want
to use the information that appears on
the
footprint into your existing bar chart
you can do that now right that's what
makes the toolbox so unique right and
not only that you can use it on other
time frames and put it on your existing
um chart right like here right this is
the 1 minute chart say you trade a one
minute chart of V minis but you know
what you think
that stacked and balances are important
okay
well if you want to you know imagine if
a stack in Balance comes in on a FIV
minute chart it's probably important
information right so now you can use
that information in your own um existing
chart that maybe you have your other
indicators working on okay so you know
that's the uh Power
of the toolbox now I'm going to turn it
over to Pablo so that he can you know
discuss with you markers you know ways
you can use
markers in automating your trading right
because you at the end of the day become
a better Trader you do need
some you if you have some method of
automating your system it's going to
help you uh come out ahead okay so Pablo
are you there
yeah hello hello
everyone okay very very nice software
really really nice having I like the
minimalistic point of view because uh
the trading ah you yeah I can share my
screen perfect uh show my screen where I
can select my
monitor this one
yeah looks
good
okay so thank you for H letting me show
this software and for those who don't
know um what is markers let let me do a
brief brief H
review um markers is a tool that lets
you create an automate signals today we
are going to analyze the part of
automation okay so and even more we have
a 30% discount but you need to wait
until the end of the presentation so you
will know which is the the coupon okay
and the coupon is not going to last for
many time so let's see let's say that
you have a signal okay we already saw on
on orderflows toolbox that it is very
minimalistic so you can see the signal
sh a signal so now that you have a
signal you want to automate it okay so
what can we do not only with this signal
but with any signal from any indicator
okay so you can copy the signal with
marker copy you will see a little dot
overlapping the original signal you can
hide it if if you don't like it but
usually when you are H configuring the
system you you want to check that they
match okay so what you trade is what you
see and then just adding marker plus
that as you can see you have options to
enable the Longs enable the shorts
enable both ways you have also filters
you you have a place to select the
account there's also a place to select
the ATM because this executes ATM orders
and you you you I guess you already know
the power of the ATM orders where we can
Define multiple positions each position
with multiple targets and trailing stop
Etc so yes we can automate with Market
this is the basic
okay but we can do a lot of more things
as we saw with the orderflow tool
toolbox now we can a like to say filter
where we have two or more signals no but
only from orderflow what happens if you
have a an orderflow signal and something
else for example here we have long
signal number one long signal number two
maybe one of them is from order flows
the other is from another custom
indicator that you may have what we can
do now is measure that distance between
the two signals and if they are at no
more than certain number of bars that
can be one okay if if you set one bar
they must be on the same bar and then we
can group those signals and create a
unique signal and then markers will Tre
Trier only when we have the two signals
at a minimum a maximum distance of a
certain number of bars
okay what else
because looking at this H chart we can
see that we have a long in the middle
that is a the market is going down and
it is a
long in fact there it should not be a
problem because that long is reversed to
short so nothing happens but you can add
a filter for example what filter any
filter let's say a moving average any
moving average or any line from any
indicator that you have on your platform
and then what you can check if the
signal is above or below the line or you
can check the slope of the line in this
case this line is always sloping down
that means that if we use the slope of
the line as a filter this signal is okay
this signal is not okay and the other
two are perfect okay so with a very
simple filter we can improve the
performance of the
signals now what can we do in total with
matter because this is not a
everything so as we already saw we can
detect signals and when that happens we
execute an order the order can be an
entry but also can be an exit Okay
usually we enter with a signal and then
we Define an ATM to set the targets and
stops and Trail Lings Etc but in the of
that we can have exit signals
okay we can filter those signals with
anything that we have installed on the
platform any indicator any condition we
can group signals as we already
so and also this is very important we
can read the values of any indicator
plot if you have a an an exponential
moving average it has only one plot the
line but if you have a Binger you have
three plots the middle line the upper
and the lower the same for the Donan Etc
so you can read any plot from any line
from any
indicator and what can we do with those
values you can calculate distances
slopes you can do math calculation for
example if the price is greater than the
line but the the other line is going up
and also the VAR green and Etc a lot of
Etc then you create a signal and finally
create signals okay and you can Shin
this with your our indicators with
orderflow indicators and showing all
together and I guess we are finishing
yes so we have a 30% discount only for
those who are still here ER watching
this and that means that you can
purchase markers that as you can see by
default the price is
570 at only
399 okay but you need a a coupon for
that and that coupon is not going to
last
forever it is a limited number of H
sales the coupon code is order flow you
can use upper case lower case whatever
you may say okay where is the site for
those who don't
know if you want more info you can
contact me at Pablo atthe indicator
store.com this is my page and let me
show my page so I can give you an
idea of where is the markers you can
click directly on markers or go to
marker systems and show all markers
systems you have one machine ID two
machine ID uh release this is the one I
was commenting
okay and also if if we have time you can
interrupt me anytime Mike I have a chart
here
loaded with an
example
but ER I have a video also where I
explained how to do this but let me show
how simple it is look take a look at
let's take a look at the indicators okay
so I have the New Order flows uh
toolbox and currently it is said to look
only at enable align po okay PCS I I
think it is um point of control no um
everything else is disabled okay then we
need to copy sorry but H if you look at
the plots at the bottom we can see that
this indicator is drawing triangle ups
and triangle Downs in color blue and red
and this is what we see
here a blue triangle a red triangle the
dots are from the copies and they are
visible just to check that they are okay
because if I this indicator has a lot of
parameters if we make a mistake in one
of the parameters what I copy is not
what I see so on markers copy
I choose a name for example the name is
go long and we can see at the bottom
that markers is expecting for go long
and go short to trigger an order okay so
we create the fast signal go long
looking at this indicator okay and the
indicator if you click is set with the
same parameters as the indicator visible
on the chat
okay and at the bottom we are selecting
The Bu signal okay and
also the settings for the markers copy
is a San dot so we can
see it on the chart if you don't like or
if you already check it that it is
working correct and you don't want to
see the dot you can turn off from this
place show copied or don't show the
copied Dot the same for the
other this is the go short fast signal
go short and it is looking at the same
indicator the same
parameters uh but the cell signal plot
okay and the configuration is a yellow
dot as we can see
here even more the original indicator is
just here for visual you can remove the
indicator because marker is just copying
the signals and executing those signals
so this is for visual you can remove it
if you want to save time for examp if
you want to make the the the chart more
to refresh faster okay because each
indicator has a time to calculate so if
we are drawing an indicator it has its
time then we copy the indicator another
time and so so on so we can remove the
indicator we only need the copy for the
Longs the copy for the shorts and then
the most important tool is markers where
first of all all of this is can be
selected from the toolbar okay the
account the ATM Etc then the fast signal
name we can also detect objects okay but
this is not the case here we are using
fast signals
and the entry method because we can
enter at Market or we can place a limit
order or a stop order above or below the
market and wait for a certain number of
bars to to get a f and of course we have
daily
limits time windows for example three
time windows so you can make it really
complex time to close the positions Etc
okay we can Define filters and also exit
conditions the exit conditions are
signals that you need to create or copy
from another
place and that's
all let me know if you have any question
but mik the mic is yours yeah thanks uh
thanks Pablo
um yeah it's you know guys bues markers
I've have had for many years already um
you know I don't know what year we're
now
2025 I think around
20 19 2020 I guess or maybe maybe even
before yeah just uh like a year before
Co sh in but um you know this is I I
I've recommended this software to a lot
of Traders over the years because you
know they're always looking for tools
that are going to help them in their
trading and you know because there's
there's a question here from um Charles
you know how to filter the market which
goes
sideways you can actually do that sort
of you know by combining um you know
like a a moving average in a sense um
you know sort of this the slope I know
Pablo's got videos on that actually you
know guys pao's got a a big uh YouTube
channel and he just posted a video
yesterday with uh tool box on there but
I
know um you know I I do sometimes watch
some of his videos to get ideas for you
know how to filter things because you
know markers does you can
filter um you know imagine using a slope
of you know like a rate or a rate of
change um you could add that into you
know your setup with with uh copy I
believe right Pablo I think that's how
you would do it um but yeah know it's
it's it's a great software so it is
possible someone asked you know do you
need level two no you just need level
one it's uh is
very very useful um you don't need to
get you know extra data or anything like
that um rain asks about uh you know a
coupon for two machine IDs I I suggest
you just reach out to Pablo um is Pablo
at the indicator store is his
email um you know I'm sure he'll get you
sorted out now you know his link is
there uh the indicator store uh you know
let me just pull my screen back here
real quick
uh hang on
here if you go to let me get a let me
just get a quick
uh
browser so you'll see it here right so
the indicator store right if you type
in people do ask me this the
indicator
store.com you'll see up here it'll say
the indicator Market Pablo's one and the
same um but you see down here is markers
plus you use that coupon overflows in
here when you check out um but rain
ify rain is asking specifically um if
there's a coupon code for the two
um if you let me the coupon is the same
okay it's okay so it's the same so you'd
get 30% off on the two uh license which
is a good deal um I'll be honest when I
bought my copy years ago I did I did use
it I did get it when it was on sale also
but um his you know his contact
information is down in here you can
always send you if you want to reach out
to him um you could do that but I
believe his email is in there somewhere
um
yeah as well so it's yeah I said it's a
really good deal it's a big savings
30% is you know it's not chump change
right because even 570 down to like what
$399 you know that's almost uh that's
almost $200 that's that's a great deal
I'm GNA go through a couple questions
here really quick uh since we got some
time uh let me see here can markers
automate orderflows Trader eight signals
um well you know that's one of one of
the reasons why we created the toolbox
because with oros Trader 8 it's more on
the footprint the the toolbox is not a
footprint chart it's designed to work on
a bar chart
to analyze the the same order flow that
you would if you're looking at a
footprint chart so because when you look
at a footprint chart normally you're
looking for certain things to happen
right you're looking for um you know
certain PC a PC to here in a certain
spot or you know imbalances coming in in
a certain area or lack of volume now
with the toolbox right it will show that
to you but not only that you can combine
it with other tools of orderflow like
the Delta analysis things like that to
create your own custom indicator um but
the toolbox is not a footprint chart but
it's analyzing the data sort of in the
background of
your um of your bar chart and it can
plot it now sometimes people will say
well you know I I want to
just let me get the chart here so what
they'll do is they'll say well you know
I want to
see signal for multiple imbalances as
well as a signal for um you know a big
Delta number right or a big volume
number but I want them to show
separately okay well you could do that
you just add you just go in there you
would add uh toolbox again with just
that one signal okay so for example all
you would do
is right you just add say you want to
look at two different things all right
you just add two copies or not two
copies but you know add two
configurations of the toolbox down in
here you know one would
be you would just choose uh volume and
balance right
three okay and then you know just to
keep it different I I'll just make it
bigger
15 15 and then that's the volume in
Balance if I wanted to add you know bars
that had over I say I was going to look
at volume okay I'm I'm just picking
something really quickly here volume
over
5,000 okay so bars got to have in this
instance bar volume over
5,000 and the other one is volume and
balance now it's going to be plotted as
two separate I would just change it you
know I don't know change a different
color make it magenta
and green okay then just hit apply that
way it would show two different ones so
you can combine them or you can keep
them separate you know again if you're
using a footprint or using a bar chart
you do the same thing
okay um can you automate it this one I'm
not sure proba would have can you
automate an indicator that repaints you
probably not want to automate an
indicator that repaints because then it
wouldn't give you yeah yes you can but
imagine watching this live you get you
get a signal you execute the order and
then on the repaint the signal is
deleted so yes you can but I I don't
suggest doing that okay um there's a
question for you Pablo um Neil says your
stuff is
great he ask if you have a trade
copier no okay yeah not yet and you know
what guys uh bubble and I were just
talking about this before
um before the
presentation and I'm sure you have all
heard the news with uh
Kraken uh by Ninja Trader you know we
don't know yet but we're hoping that
uh Kraken is going to connect a ninja
Trader somehow so imagine being able to
trade all the
different cryptos with Trader right so
that's why it's uh hopefully it's good
times
ahead you know not that Futures isn't a
good product Futures are great to trade
but uh you know it's you know crypto is
is a old different Beast it's 247 never
ends um and it's it's a legitimate
exchange you know kraken's been been
around for a long time so hopefully
they're going to expand it into ninja
Trader so it's like uh you know imagine
being right the way I look at it is you
know imagine being at Disney World and
Mickey Mouse comes up to you and says
hey instead of standing in this line why
don't you come up to the front that's
what you're going to be able to do
hopefully when if Kraken connects to
ninja Trader imagine you have all this
you know this the software to trade to
automate your trading to analyze the
order
flow ahead of all these other Traders
out there I mean trading view does have
quote a footprint chart but the way they
handle the data is vastly different than
it's not an accurate representation of
the actual trading that's taking place
right they they're aggregating trades
over time and trust me the I've been
meaning to make a video on it for a
while but the data on trading views
footprint is is incredibly different
it's almost uh negligent on their part
because they know they got a a nice
platform but the way that they handle
the data coming in um it's just not it's
not accurate representation of how it's
trading in the market but hopefully with
Kraken being able to connect a ninja
Trader and you have already markers you
already have a tool like the toolbox or
you know existing way of trading the
market you're going to be ahead of all
those other Traders out there the retail
traders that are getting in you know
that want to trade crypto they're
they're so far behind the curve
right that's where you're going to find
an edge in the market that's that's why
I'm excited for what the future holds
with Kraken buying ninja Trader um yeah
I think it's going to give us Traders a
uh a great opportunity um someone's
asking about your YouTube channel let me
just uh pull it up here really really
quick if I can uh Well's go to
YouTube and let's see here oh you just
type in here the indicator
store and you can find it here it's just
called here so you see posted a video
yesterday on uh how to automate
orderflows toolbox signals on ninja
Trader he's got videos on using a VPS
he's got a lot of videos up here he's
got the nice little Channel going here
so how many videos you got uh there's a
lot and and you know the nice thing like
I said you know I've been working with
Pablo for
years he's been around a long time all
right it's not like one of these Fly by
Night guys that just creates an
indicator then they disappear so he's
always
there he's easy to reach you know he's
even got uh I think you have a Discord
too right I think um Pablo but uh yeah
so it's it's you know it's a nice
software so again you know for my
software just go to orderflows docomo
boox now right now and I know whoops I
know Pablo's got a special deal on on
his software on the toolbox if you go to
the toolbox website let me just get it
here right I actually have a deal as
well I don't have a coupon code but we
have a
deal normally it's
$4.99 but we're lowering the price down
to S by $700 is
$7.99 okay the the reason being is again
it's this is not something that I've
really actively promoted it's really
been
for um my existing users of the order
flows Trader software that already
understand orderflow because again you
know at the end of the day orderflow is
something that's not for everybody okay
you know some Traders trade on more of a
bigger time frame they you know don't
necessarily buy into orderflow they want
to live in this world of moving averages
and whatever you know theyy more power
to you if that's what works for you but
for the traders that really understand
orderflow the power of it and want to be
ahead of everybody else you know that's
who we really marketed to the order
flows toolbox to right because it's been
it's an easy transition all right
but for not now because of this Pres
presentation because you know a lot of
people I know they they've been always
asking me hey how can I how can I
combine signals create my own
indicator and then automate it so
basically all you need is just the
toolbox and
markers and you're good to
go right basically so it's it's it's uh
very easy to use Brian asks is level two
not needed for the orderflows toolbox no
you don't need level two for the toolbox
right just one because what the toolbox
is analyzing right it's just it's
analyzing the actual orderflow as it's
trading in the
background of the bar
chart okay so you know once you
understand what the tool is used for and
again it's all explained in the user
guide okay so you know sometimes people
get so caught up in oh you know I don't
understand what this mean what align
point of control is well for example you
know align point of control is two point
of controls that come in the
same price level over two consecutive
bars right and you can see there's one
taking place literally right here this
was this afternoon at uh just afternoon
1204 1205 right that's a bearish signal
and you see the market sold off about
seven points from that very quickly you
know order flow in my opinion is best
used as soon as it peers right that's
why using a tool like markers in my
opinion will help Traders a lot
because it's sort of it's removing that
step of the trade entry where you're
like trying to identify this with your
eyes and then click the sell button
right so Toolbox will identify this
markers will execute your
trade okay then you can manage it all
right trust me managing a trade
is a lot less stressful than trying to
analyze the order flow especially if
you're sort of newer to order flow you
know what you want to look
for and then clicking the sell
button let the software do that let the
software analyze what you like to look
for and then tell markers execute it
right and then you can you know either
just let the trade play out or you know
you could watch how the market is
developing if it doesn't look like it's
uh you know you can see down here it
starts selling off nicely but then it
starts going
sideways you know how could you tell
question K Charles asked how can you
tell Market's going sideways well
there's different ways you can read the
order flow obviously positive Delta
negative positive negative
positive we sort of flip flopping back
and forth with no clear Direction that's
a sign okay maybe you cut the trade here
right but the important thing is you're
in the trade last thing you want to do
is have something actionable like here
right with the twooter controls being
bearish and you get in late right
instead of getting in you know right
away say 5628 you're getting in here
you're giving up two points at 5626
because you're Heming and hawing for
whatever reason and you're getting short
at 26 and basically the market trades
down to about 20 you we'll call it 24
where would you rather be short from 26
or
28 right there's extra two points right
there that you you you gave up just
because you're like yeah you know and
trust me Traders do that all the time
right it's like the uh psychological
aspect of trading people don't realize
how important it is
but hesitation whether it's trading or
sports or anything costs opportunity all
right so um let me just uh pull up that
again
so again you know for the toolbox go to
orderflows docomo boox
for Pablo's um markers right he's got a
coupon code you just go to his website
the
indicator store just type in the
indicator store um you'll see markers
Plus on the front you'll find it in here
go to marketers plus this coupon code is
uh orderflows I believe so you just type
it in there when you check out so we're
going to end it there this this will be
recorded but again you know remember
Pablo's coupon only lasts for um it's a
limited time right and you I hate to use
the the saying um you snooze you lose my
kids like to say to me too bad too sad
you know when I miss something but um
you know time I hate to say time is
money that sounds so cliche but you know
it's a great deal and you got to take
advant of these deals when they come up
you know like I said you know when I got
markers I did buy it on a discount years
ago um you know would you rather pay
it's like my wife you know tell her to
use a coupon sometimes ah you know it's
too complicated to use a coupon well I'm
like why pay full price when you can get
it now at a discount okay so again you
know Pablo's 30% off deal is is a very
good deal so take advantage of it and uh
you know Pablo thanks for coming out
today thanks everyone for um for coming
out on your Friday afternoon you know I
know I'm here in Chicago in the bar the
the weather is starting to get uh much
better and uh hopefully where all you
guys are at this spring is coming and I
hope you guys got good weather so thanks
Pablo and thanks everyone for coming out
today and yes this will be recorded
we'll send it out um you know later once
it gets all processed and and everything
so have a great weekend everyone thanks
again Pablo and I'll catch you guys
later thank you you bye-bye
bye-bye
e
e for